alors m'a dit tu vas faire une tournée
mondiale et tu peux te le permettre car
tu es déjà presque une star aux
etats-unis parce qu en fait d'après les
médias américains tués presque le
chanteur drake ya eu cette histoire mais
c'est vrai alors on va embarrasser y
regarder on y va on va revoir puisque
apparemment août aurait confondu
parce que tu dîner avec la mère de
l'enfant de drake et on t'aurait
confondues pour pas voilà mais on peut
voir donc après il ya eu des articles et
on disait que elle mangeait avec drake
elle dînait avec drake et regarde ça se
voit d'ailleurs règle dans les médias
américains le couvent avec ma dîme
entamé il ya quelque chose en moi cette
région tour d'oreille moi c'est vrai
qu'on dirait que c'est la même
oui la moitié se trouve plus beau voir
si je te dis vous de ma gueule adhésion
continue les notes c'est ça alors donc
malige sud il ya pas mal de stars qui
ont des sous titres est saisissant on
sait pas toujours déceler le vrai du
faux regardez moi par exemple vous le
savez peut-être pas mais c'est vrai que
je vous l'avais dit je suis fan de foot
et je me souviens même pas si c'est moi
ou un sosie qui était dans ce stade par
exemple près de nous deux ça c'est oit
alors on a aussi cru voir gad elmaleh
qui prépare la suite du film chouchou
regardez gad elmaleh s'est inspiré josé
garcia qui lui aussi joue un rôle de
traversy vous de travestis pour son
prochain film regardé josé garcia c'est
pas lui c'est un truc de ouf
il ya quelqu'un que j'adore qui s'est
reconverti pour devenir scout c'est
patrick sébastien regarder patrick
sébastien au su des stars américaines
qui ont aidé reconversion étonnante
leonardo dicaprio va se reconvertir dans
l'armée alors là alors c'est son sosie
ces poissons se disent pas ou alors vous
qui connaissez ben elton john raymond
l'a vu s'éclater comme un fou à la fête
foraine de bobos je regardais
[Applaudissements]
je vous jure c'est vrai que j'ai choisi
les chérit sa nissan sont que des choses
comme ça non non c'est un saisie comme
ça il est à la fête foraine de maubeuge
et c'est fin qu'il ya une bonne nouvelle
pour nous français c'est que 6 ou
s'exile aux après un passage compliqué
au real on revient en france avec notre
ancien président françois hollande qui a
visiblement changé de vie et quitte la
corée et enfin et on fait enfin regarder
on a retrouvé le père de benjamin cassel
x vous l'avait déjà mise vous avez déjà
mises arrêté trois soirs d'été la photo
arrêté mais je ne suis pas content
non mais je vous jure arrêter avec cette
photo on avait dit pas les vraies photos
de soi que sosie la droite en liberté
hier à la paire castany